[Music]
in what's your Excuse news submitted by
sponsor heard Nike an 11 year old
athlete won multiple gold medals running
in shoes made from bandages what the
[ __ ] why she's probably poor oh I
thought she was a DIY youtubers of them
get shoes for 10 bucks all right dig
yourself out the hole keep no thank you
excuse me think about a bandage right
how many bands is it gonna take to cover
a foot is this a name-brand bandage yeah
what if we get some like cheap-ass light
you get the [ __ ] well Fred cross like
Kate broke up brought the shipment in to
your country then maybe you is free this
is in Florida and also who did she win
the gold medals against oh come on yeah
I mean other bandits Childress no badge
does she really need a sponsor from Nike
everyone's kind of like yeah of course
she needs a sponsor we need to examine
these things all right
so RIA she's an 11 year old student at
this some elementary school in the
Philippines and she has won three gold
medals even though she didn't have
proper shoes on so she managed to win
the 400 meter dash the 800 meter run and
the 1500 meter run in the girls category
which is pretty much a mile wearing just
these shoes well do you know that's why
they made Rose so she drew the swoosh
and lakeyanna how does she have such a
nice uniform but no she wasn't that
copyright so thank you should sue she's
going down made those shoes with the
toes yeah the fibers
yeah and all the runners bought them
because supposedly you run better if
you're barefoot and like you're meant to
run barefoot yeah maybe that's what she
was doing and she's not poor and we're
assuming Yeah right
maybe Nike better protect their brand
yeah she's coming after him well this
went viral do we have her time to race
hands I don't have that [ __ ] on a race
to be like No
amateur hours because if the other
filipinos are just being lazy and just
you know not really pushing hard then
the gold medal should return them yeah
do we know if the other Filipinos are
being lazy we don't know that okay thank
you
so after news of her gold medals spread
like one barrel because of her makeshift
shoes that's when a lot of news outlets
picked it up and then Jeff Curry
cross Co cross oh sorry a retired
basketball player and the coach of the
Alaska Aces
he was so amazed by this girls never
heard of that team Alaska Aces dude I
just found out about a new team to the
[ __ ] what was that team baby weird
Bahamas yeah there's a basketball team
I'd never heard of the Bahama burglars
where the [ __ ] did they come from
oh they change your name I mean the
Charlotte Hornets went to New Orleans
yeah okay another pelicans what's a bit
[ __ ] room what the [ __ ] is that
Alaskan aces is that is that NBA or is
that some other league he asked the
internet to help him get in touch with
her and her coaches and so he did like
the internet helped he managed to reach
them and then he put them in touch with
Nike oh sit so now the whole team could
receive proper footwear oh yeah how does
the second-place person feel with shoes
on feel yeah absolutely everyone had
running shoes except for her
yeah she wants that's her that's her
strategy maybe she's gonna lose in those
Nikes I was gonna say what if she went
worse than the night Oh Alaska Aces is
the ice hockey team
yeah yeah I can I could say go aces now
track hey go pelicans just like a
terrible name I was like maybe their
basketball team couldn't practice for a
while because of Katrina and then he'd
Steve was like they should have named
their team the Katrina's that would have
been more scary scary threatening yeah
[Laughter]
right good see that's better okay
California greatness earthquakes is
pretty sick it was a wrestling name
earthquake when I watch WWF back in the
day
cool story [ __ ] you kid anyway yeah it's
just the cute story here let me show you
oh she's cute she's cute but you're
loving years old
nice well Nikki yeah pretty much those
shoes look like they're intentional now
that I look at it well she knew what she
was doing she knows like what which
surface is gonna make contour 11th
you're doing that what if she has to put
like reapply them for every like race
we're not like tires oh right
degree retread the hood I wonder if your
feet are sticky oh yeah with the
adhesive she showers with and I wonder
if there's a her track only band-aids no
like said you know you know like some
basketball players they don't wear their
their race shoes outside
these are track tires yeah isn't my
track shoes I'm not gonna what he's in
parking lot in the parking lot I just
think if I'm I found my deed is I'm a
little offended the bug she sees her
teammate she lost though I mean you
could be in the same team a still race
against it that's like when the swimmers
like it's a get first place America
second place America yeah they're like
oh well I still got second place sucks
yeah yeah I know you're not supposed to
have you guys are ran barefoot I'm what
you think about on the beach from my
shower to my toilet are you right well
our bathroom is pretty big
I just walk around barefoot in Atlantis
in the Bahamas the entire time that's
true because sandals [ __ ] my feet up
running though Steve doesn't run I would
run from a natural disaster what do you
like running barefoot on hard on the
hard surface I'm like I thought that
would hurt her
yeah you're you have to be pretty
calloused for it to not hurt it always
gets me as the heat though like if it's
right if you're walking across like
concrete or asphalt or sand yeah like
it's just like but it's crazy how like
the top layer of sand is hot as [ __ ] and
then you just go like two inches down
it's cool it is cool yeah what's crazy
she ran three races that day yeah maybe
she has a callus probably if she doesn't
have shoes no what if she just says
she's at home though she's like no she's
probably walking around the bottom of
our feet are surprisingly resilient
though like yeah you kept saying that in
the Bahamas on the bottom of my feet
with no shoes and he was like bragging
about his feet he's like how we'll say
the bottom of my feet are pretty
resilient 15 time I've heard this today
compared to what were you just like
looking at all these other people like
confident like haha they're all wearing
sandals wearing people Footwear wearing
creeping mean it's not like Joey what do
you mean you don't want to live out a
poem I like to jack off yeah I was like
when we have a new guest and Joe says
some [ __ ] about jacking off or whatever
that guess is always like [ __ ]
shocked yeah yeah they should be but
they're usually comedians and they're
like I can't believe it's kind of just
said that yeah because that's Joe that's
remember Joe seeing anything shocking
when I was a guest see there you go my
first time as a guest
I think he's progressively like been
more shot I think you shocked me
actually cuz I think you were on a guest
as why not ask the feels first oh yeah
and then I remember
you're telling us how you masturbate if
there's long driving no way you're
driving no Mike whoa she's open like we
are that's cool see my driving is way
better than yours I know jack and I'm
driving no I don't know if we can do it
as good as they can they can do they can
jerk off like pretty like with utility
with slow small movements Drive and jerk
off it's just not gonna work guys
let me squeeze it would that do anything
you wish anyway I did have a question
for you part since we are talking about
running and stuff you you're saying
you're trying to do America yeah I was
thinking about why not I was thinking
about and I signed up yesterday oh [ __ ]
when's the marathon is it that way
marathon okay yeah I do
well I've never done even a half
marathon so I think I'm gonna do a half
a mess because Canyon Rescue has it so
that you can run the LA Marathon for
them so it's like you're sponsoring them
while you're running oh cool yeah what's
Ken risky
it's my favorite yeah kitten rescue is
my favorite cat charity they like make
sure that it's our favorite cat shirt
yeah yes because well there's a lot that
just take your money and then they
actually kill the cats they don't care
no kid rescues awesome I know I know
them they're great
you're gonna these animal places they're
[ __ ] up like PETA is [ __ ] up and I
will go on record saying that people
have they've tried to sponsor me I'm
like hell no you kill animals anyway so
they do the thing where you can run the
LA Marathon for them okay I kind of want
to do it 26 miles no I want to do the
half one I hired I heard that's what I
my Marathon coach told me I hired one
what what do you do the programming you
need like 12 it's a good way to trainer
like yes so yeah I hit her up and then
she was like oh how about this why don't
we have you do a half marathon and then
we can program for the full marathon and
I'm like [ __ ] that I ain't no [ __ ] I'm
gonna do
former Zambia word so uh have you ever
done a 10k no so you never done you
didn't buy any kind of like running like
event thing um not really
join the space program burg [ __ ]
boring people do something different
than the rest of people Bart do
something that nobody's doing clean my
butthole in the ocean I've already done
that no no no that's pretty good but
during the space program be coming out
Apollo astronauts did you just say you
want to go balls deep in than [ __ ]
man no but I don't have 20 years to
accomplish this I want some love doing
like a couple boys yeah we are in
December but I did sign up so if you
want to yeah March 8th and you run from
the Dodger Stadium alley to Santa Monica
what you can't even drive that in like a
day block off the streets oh yeah they
block off the street so everyone's
[ __ ] in traffic thanks a lot should
have been walking should have been
running that day my very first day like
I had a job the first day I moved to LA
like I moved and then like the next day
was like the more fruit my first day on
the job
it was the LA Marathon and all the roads
were blocked and I was like 2 hours late
to my yeah cuz I didn't know the roads
yet at all so I only knew my GPS and
like they didn't have alternate routes
[ __ ] because like let's say this is
the 10 freeway right and like let's say
they block off like this part of it this
entire Street if you somehow made it to
under this street and you need to get to
the 10 for you cuz we were stuck in
k-town one time we tried every single
Street and you're just stuck all the way
until the next opening and each Street
has a bunch of traffic because each
person like they're all trying to figure
out how to get out of it and you're like
why the [ __ ] did I turn here we take
Sepulveda down to the to Gallup or take
the 134 well
[Music]
[Music]